i sat down for an exclusive injury with
Chet Kanodia the founder and CEO of
Aereo the broadcast TV streaming service
which filed for bankruptcy last week
after the Supreme Court Judge it's
service violated copyright laws while in
an exclusive interview Kanodia told me
the true underlying reason he thinks the
legal system dismissed his company fine
is 20/20 but I just think that there was
novelty is a big issue it seems like in
the legal system if you're new and
you're different
you must be scary at least that's an
outsider's obviously I have no idea what
close inside this reporter does or any
court for that matter and you know
novelty scares people at the end of the
day I think if you take a step back and
say what did this company really do is
it was opening up a marketplace using
complete you know and multiple that of
course it found that we were absolutely
right
now say that it felt like it was a
incorrect decision from our perspective
and to the extent that there was
discomfort and from at least from my
perspective and I think that dissent
sort of said this to the extent that is
discomfort in this prevailing Congress
is perfectly capable of fixing these
things and in fact the incumbents have a
lot more control over the congressional
process they have a lot more lobbyists
to spend a lot more money than around
the block a few more times and let's not
forget they've done this multitude of
times they've changed laws to
accommodate for new technology they
should and I think you know it's
probably appropriate to be very clear
either that's obviously area has a
perspective on this because we had an
axe to grind I understand that and the
court probably wisely incorrectly
however you look at it and took their
view and it is what it is the area your
technology was not intended for any old
content it was only very specifically
the broadcast TV which was free to air
so the argument we used obviously that
didn't succeed was you know consumer has
the right to an antenna it done really
matter what the containers antennas low
locator on my roof or on my handheld or
it's a central antenna that I'm leasing
or the specific technological
implementation is irrelevant
that was our event in the court said
well it's actually we how you do it
doesn't really matter if it looks like
cable TV to a company we must treat you
as such you must pay for that content
well that's actually where it's even
harder to understand the law as it sort
of the compulsory license which is what
under copyright law you had acquired to
pay we were happy to pay and we actually
had filed all our filings and things
like that the challenge was the market
is evolved evolved in the early 90s in
mid nineties to just from a copyright
based payment to a retransmission
payment which is in copyright law by the
way and we were sued under copyright law
so there was this mishmash of competing
regimes that sort of came together and
and you know I think it's pretty obvious
that the day we started we built
everything to comply to the T with the
law as it existed back then and if there
was a mechanism in which there was a
framework that said this is how an
online provider is supposed to operate
we would have done that it didn't exist
it didn't exist
and so for we had to create that
argument that question in that opening
and you know we took the approach we
took because we thought it made the most
sense to drive the conversation you know
you've been immersed in this world for
three years right should content be free
should it actually just be free right
you know I believe in markets I firmly
do and I think if a content provider
wants to charge $100 a month for that
they have every right to charge $100 but
if they want to provide it for free they
have every right to provide it for free
if you're a broadcaster that's
broadcasting free-to-air to consumer
with an antenna
you can't take both sides of the
argument
that's the that's really if those
companies weren't broadcast we didn't do
this with HBO or Turner or any of those
right so she was very specifically free
to air broadcast television it had
nothing to do with you know if they
elected that said we're not afraid to
have broadcast we would like you to pay
a million dollars an hour for our
content great if the market bears it I
think that they have every right to be
able to do that